yeah say sex bro so no scary movies
i wanted to watch one every day and i
just didn't get to
yeah so we got one we watched sinister
you ever watched that movie no
it's got ethan hawk oh yeah it's where
he goes and he
he's a crime writer he writes books
about
unsolved mysteries and he goes and lives
in a house where there's an unsolved
mystery where
kids were murdered okay and it was the
most
youtuber thing you know it just or the
mo
i felt it was super modern in that like
this is something that you would see
yeah definitely you know yeah like a
dude's youtube account
yeah what's up you guys yeah as you know
i'm really really
into hauntings and and ghosts and cool
stuff like that so what we did is we
found a house where a bunch of children
were
murdered for real though and we're gonna
live here and write a book
like it was it was the most modern [ __ ]
i could see that as a whole youtube
account you know
haunted house book and guys i'll be
documenting my experience writing this
book
and you know so it's basically
a dude how do you silence this thing
pull it up like pull up the menu from
the bottom i think
now go back to the homepage or lock it
yeah oh yeah put it on do not disturb or
something
don't hit my phone yeah that's not
gonna understand yeah okay
so a bunch of you know it's basically
the it's about the boogie man
basically and he just looks like the
tenth member of slipknot it's super fun
okay like he's wearing a
just a crude mask yeah and you know he's
got
no eyes in it you know empty vacant eyes
whatever
and uh greasy ass hair
it's just super funny how telegraphed
all the jump scares were
you know one one of them is
ethan hawk is on his computer and then
he he rotates so now
his chest is perpendicular to the camera
okay so you can see his right shoulder
and across his chest
and it's super [ __ ] contrived like
he's like
he's on his computer he goes oh let me
check my phone
and then you see the the computer screen
in the background
with the frozen image of the
you know the boogie man yeah yeah and
then
the vfx just kicks in and the boogeyman
looks to camera
and then it looks like it goes back to
its regular position ethan goes
he goes back to using the computer and
he just you see it coming
you're like oh he's good it's gonna move
it moved okay and then they they would
frame [ __ ] where
i don't know i just felt like it it's
just so funny how how far horror has
come
yeah you know now they they have you
[ __ ] yourself before you go in
yeah like you're thinking about a tongue
click yeah you know you're like oh god
that sound
yeah and back then it was just like all
right ethan over here
cause then in vfx he's gonna pop out
over here yeah yeah yeah nathan's like
oh okay
really scary mask yeah he's gonna look
scary
[Laughter]
the whole time they're shooting ethan's
so what does the monster
look like they haven't figured that part
out yet but trust me we
we had a we had one of our interns go to
party city
it's to be scary they had some really
good ones there
yeah i'm just i'm really struggling to
get into the character because i have no
clue
what i'm scared of yeah we can have one
of the pas when you chuck on the mask
right there
yeah look at that oh look at how scary
that is
it's like a hockey mask it's like a like
a goalie mask
it's like what that's not even like yeah
we couldn't
we couldn't find one that everything was
sold out yeah yeah
yeah this is the best yeah i don't know
why we're shooting this on halloween but
all the masters are sold out
crazy in turn in the background
squirt some ketchup on his face look at
that
all right ethan go the best part is
like the like the the side plot is that
he didn't tell his wife he was moving
them into that house
okay and then she finds out afterward
that he moved them into the house with
the dead kids oh i see and if it wasn't
for creepy music
it looked like scenes out of marriage
story oh
it had that same just she had an english
accent too and she was a terrible
actress
the how could you move us into this
house and the pacing of the dialogue
there's no gaps
so it's like she's going ah and then he
just comes back and
they get into like hysterics and they're
crying he's like i need this this is the
best part he
he gets like emotional he's like this is
gonna be a hit for me
it's my hit i need it and i you know i
don't know it just
the whole movie is [ __ ] off they get
divorced and that's then yeah
you're like oh yeah what the it's a
scary movie about
who did going up in a broken home yeah
the boogeyman's like yo what and the
rest of the movie is just the children
like having a
tough time deciding between parents and
the boogeyman doesn't know which house
to go to
the buggy man he's a child of divorce
and then he's there with the kids like
upset i mean he's like yeah well you
know i thought you guys were going to be
in the one house
but now i have to go i like what i don't
know who to haunt anymore it feels like
i'm playing favorites and
and you know it's just making my life
hard
you know now i gotta go to the custody
hearing and try to testify
you know that it's at your dad's house
permanently because if it's up to me
it's easier
it's closer to where i live i'm just
trying to scare the [ __ ] out of people
man
is it but i don't get it so it's not the
dead kids that haunt the house
it's the boogie man well it killed the
kids it's a combination so the creepiest
part is that
you so ethan hawk's character right away
you know he goes into the attic and
there's just this random
um like case
and it's got a bang energy yeah bang
energy okay you know like porn tapes
it's he opens it up and and it's got a
high eight
film camera in there and a bunch of
neatly uh
reels you know i see yeah he's got
spielberg secret stash
so then he sets it up in his home office
which by the way the lighting in there
was so sick
it looked like like the u.n like a
creepy house
card scene or a kubrick shot i was like
someone used to take this and put it in
another movie okay
because it doesn't belong in this movie
and so he starts like watching the tapes
and
it's like all these videos of kids
i think that's just someone that's like
what's that
the boogeyman's in here in here yeah
that sounds like it's coming from right
there
it's just creepy [ __ ] like families
locked in cars and they're burning alive
oh yum yeah but you but i don't know
[Laughter]
ooh that's fun fun yeah
family is burning a lot i don't know
something about it just
yeah it i think because now
red giant has given everyone the ability
to do that high eight filter yeah i just
felt like i was watching a
bad music video i see so i just i
couldn't
i'm like no it's a scary movie it's a
scary movie a scary movie but you know
if they if they put a [ __ ] i don't
know 100 gecks under that [ __ ] i would
have been like
yeah oh this video is [ __ ] up man this
is art
i was watching the new season of eric
andre show and i was like i kind of felt
the same way about the editing i used to
think
because when i first watched that show
it was before i learned how to use
premiere and before i did editing for
four years five years now
yeah and i used to think man is editing
so wild and crazy like how do they
and now i watch the new season i'm like
this is just the jankiest just
keyframing
you can tell like they're just doing
exactly what we do for youtube videos
i mean it works and it's genius but it's
like yeah you look at it through a
different light
yeah yeah for sure yeah there's is yeah
when you know how [ __ ] works
yeah and and i think the creepiest
stuff they had in that movie was like so
he would break down the high eight
film and get creeped out and he'd hide
it and it would just magically
be reset up and running in the middle of
the night so he'd be sleeping then he
just here
oh okay i was like ah yeah that's creepy
so what what it is is that
the boogeyman follows through
these tapes and like the people he
murders
and so how he does it is he he
takes control of one of the kids and
then he murders
the family through the kids okay so that
was kind of tight every wow that's
wild it's very dark yeah at the end
you're thinking like okay they move
they move back home okay yeah so and
their daughter just [ __ ] so
not happy yeah yeah
ethan hawk dies in the craziest way
possible just big ass
axe to the [ __ ] he's like he dies in the
purge too right
he's the only one that dies i didn't
watch what you haven't seen the purge
yeah i think i might just like dude
watch that movie for halloween
yes yeah okay so the one movie that we
watched
i'll tell you about it i don't know i
[ __ ] forget what it's called you're
like uh
500 days of summer great halloween film
oh scary you never know if they're gonna
get together just isn't that zoe
deschanel right uh
is it right let me see and uh what and
the [ __ ] guy
that everyone like all the girls love
they're obsessed with it
um i'll eat it in between yeah
yeah yeah the guy everyone loves uh
danny mcbride
danny mcbride yeah yeah no dana white
they don't know why
my friend donald trump
you see that [ __ ] whoa
bro them in elk is the weirdest dude
okay ever
let's talk about that or wait i'll just
tell you about this horror movie first
then we'll talk about that
so this movie is is so it's 500 days of
summer so
zoey scares this [ __ ] um because you
think she's not going to get with danny
mcbride and you're like what are you
doing like that's a joke
so quirky and zany that it's scary it's
like how can any girl be that cool you
know
um it's like frightening because like
it's a girl with like personality and
you're like oh my god how
because that would never happen no i'm
joking about like
people people are always like that's why
that was zoey day she knows like stick
at the beginning it's like
oh she's so like weird yeah a girl with
cool is like a hipster a girl with bangs
that's not annoying
what oh my god can you imagine a girl
with bangs who's not annoying
so okay i forget who the director is
he's some famous
foreign horror director and so this was
like a
oh shia labeouf yeah
i don't even know any of the actors in
this movie
i wish i [ __ ] knew the title of this
the vacation or something like that
anyways it was like um ukrainian or
something and they made an
american version of it okay this guy's
super famous all of his films i looked
them up they all have like
crazy ratings like he's he's a famous
horror director
and so the american version of this film
is i'm just gonna
it's gonna be a spoiler alert and i wish
i could tell you the title of this movie
so you can decide if you want to watch
it later or not
um but so they go
it's like this white family the
vacationers
no um horror
no damn it hold on they go on vacation
yeah and it's basically this white
family they go to this like
waspy sort of like country club esque
house
in the middle like by a lake it's you
know giant like
yard and a perfect getaway now
afflicted
it's not nicole kidman but there's
someone that looks like her
a blonde actress that kind of looks like
her okay um
uh this is the best part [ __ ] the movie
kid this is the most
this is the most suspenseful part look a
lime yep that's it
who looks like nicole kidman naomi watts
that's what it is
let's go naomi watts horror
movie
not the ring just look at her
oh king here it is yes funny games
boom let's go
[Music]
it was funny games dude
it was it's classic it was on the tip of
my tongue
funny games okay this is what it's about
i might want to watch this dude i don't
know if i want you to spoil it okay i
won't but i kind of want to okay
you you should watch it because it it's
it was like my favorite horror movie
ever for like the first 40 minutes i've
never felt so inspired
by a movie i was like these villains are
[ __ ]
amazing yeah the best horror villains
i've ever seen
in a movie and then basically the second
half of the movie is like the director's
commentary on
the horror genre as a whole so it
completely changes pace
and you got to decide for yourself
whether you like it or not but that's
all i'll say
if you want to watch it i do okay then
we can discuss it
because it's super artistic
you